[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres la ville de plaisir vient
d'organiser son premier forum inter
générationnelle toutes les associations
étaient réunis pour réfléchir sur cette
thématique le but renforcer des échanges
entre les personnes âgées et les plus
jeunes
samedi dernier les assistantes
maternelles manifesté à versailles elle
dénonce un courrier du conseil
départemental les empêchant de se
regrouper en dehors de leur domicile et
revendiquent de meilleures conditions de
travail
cette semaine la rédaction vous propose
une série de reportages sur le mariage
on débute avec anaïs et florence de
wedding planner basée à trappes
leur mission organiser votre réception
de a à z
on ouvre ce journal avec l'hommage
national aux policiers xavier juge il
est assassiné la semaine dernière sur
les champs elysées un attentat
revendiqué par des shs attrape les
drapeaux ont été mis en berne à l'hôtel
de ville ce matin et une minute de
silence a été observée
le maire de la ville guy malandain a
exprimé son émotion au micro de camille
lambert
c'est un geste simple mais dont la
signification est est très forte dans la
situation dans laquelle on est et et
dans l'évolution de de nos institutions
et de notre façon d'être
d'abord la fraternité l'égalité la
liberté avant toutes ces affaires de
haine
chaque personne est unique et elle loi
elle doit être respectée et donc je
crois que s'il n'y a pas de fraternité
finalement il n'y a pas de liberté
on en parlait dans les titres le lien
entre les générations est au coeur des
préoccupations a plaisir à forum était
organisé hier avec toutes les
associations de la ville
le but réfléchir aux moyens de renforcer
les échanges entre les personnes âgées
et les plus jeunes un reportage d'anne
laure l'anguille
du rire de la réflexion et des échanges
une soixantaine de professionnels
invités par la ville de plaisir
partagent leur expérience de travail
avec plusieurs générations pour cette
employée de la mairie le bienfait du
lien entre les populations ne fait aucun
doute
moi je suis amené à travailler avec les
enfants et le fait que ça passe par des
nous est né ou des personnes en eau
potable plus âgés que les enfants il ya
un côté encore plus éducatif
les participants de ce tout premier
forum doivent trouver des idées pour
renforcer encore le contact entre
générations repas spectacle cours
d'informatique
tout est évoquée est alors une idée là
qu'il m'a séduite qui a été évoqué en
fin de groupe de travail qui serait de
faire un théâtre de rue en faisant
participer les habitants jeunes et moins
jeunes et en essayant de réunir au
maximum les quartiers de la ville les
élus de plaisir l'ont bien constaté les
liens entre les habitants de la ville
s'effrite et paradoxalement notre monde
hyperconnecté n'arrange rien on
communique mais est ce qu'on les change
véritablement je suis pas certaine les
réseaux sociaux on s'envoie des petits
messages on se parle c'est très bref ça
y'a pas de je pense que non on a perdu
ce lien avec les réseaux sociaux les
meilleures idées de cette journée de
travail seront présentées au conseil
municipal de plaisir à la rentrée en vue
d'être appliquée dès l'an prochain
elle encourt sept terrains tout autre
forum qui est organisée en partenariat
avec la commune de maurepas le deuxième
forum de l'immobilier et de
l'aménagement de l'habitat
il s'est déroulé au complexe sportif
europe près de 40 professionnels du
secteur étaient présents écoutent et
grégory gary astier le maire de maurepas
nous sommes deux villes qui sont liés
par l'histoire aussi construction de la
ville nouvelle dans les années 60 et
donc de réunir tous les partenaires
constructeurs aménageurs les banques en
même temps et aussi des entreprises pour
la rénovation de l'habitat des agences
immobilières également permet aux
habitants sur un même lieu
le pouvoir faire leur choix pour acheter
ou louer des logements l'idée aussi est
de s'engager dans des projets de
construction
c'est de rendre attractif nos
territoires mais aussi de permettre à
ceux qui travaillent sur le territoire
de s'y loger avec leur famille elles
veulent dollar aux connaissances les
assistantes maternelles manifesté samedi
dernier pour que soient prises en compte
les difficultés de leur métier elle
dénonçait un courrier du conseil
départemental les empêchant de se
regrouper en dehors de leur domicile
regardez c'est ce courrier qui a tout
déclenché une lettre datée du 17
novembre 2016
envoyé par le conseil départemental elle
pose problème parce qu'en fait on nous
interdit selon la première lettre de
nous rassembler en association en fait
on nous occulte complètement c'est dire
qu'on nous dit on depuis des années on
nous dit de nous professionnaliser un ce
qu'on fait à on prend du temps sans le
samedi pour aller en formation quand
même et de l'autre côté on fait comme si
on n'était pas capable de gérer des
temps d'accueil collectif pour proposer
des activités aux enfants pour proposer
la sociabilisation
samedi dernier une quinzaine d'entre
elles se rassembler à versailles au delà
du courrier elle souhaite une
reconnaissance de leur profession ce qui
concerne le salaire c'est sûr que c'est
un peu compliqué parce que pour avoir le
smic il faut avoir trois ou quatre
enfants des fois et plus le temps de
travail c'est c'est beaucoup beaucoup
moi je suis à 45 heures par semaine avec
trois enfants n'a pas de santé on n'a
pas de médecine du travail
on n'a aucune obligation d'aller voir le
médecin on a juste une fois par an va
voir le médecin qui nommé apte pour
continuer notre travail pour avoir
l'agrément
selon la cgt plus de 8000 assistantes
maternelles travaillent dans les
yvelines
cette semaine la rédaction vous propose
une série sur les mariages organiser cet
événement n'est pas toujours chose
facile pour se débarrasser du stress
certains confie cette mission à des
wedding planner comme à nice et florence
deux organisatrices installé à trappes
il n'y avait pas de mobilier extérieur
je ne sais pas si vous allez en avoir
besoin mais en tout cas il n'y a pas de
chaise pour l'extérieur
effectivement effectivement on n'y a pas
un lien pas forcément pensé salle de
réception organisation des menus
s'occuper de l'animation organiser son
mariage peut vite devenir un casse tête
pour éviter que le plus beau jour de sa
vie ne devienne un cauchemar ce client
installé à hong kong a décidé de s'en
remettre anaïs et florence de wedding
planner leur but réaliser votre rêve
la plus value c'est que on va s'occuper
tout niveau on est très sereins il y
aura moins de stress parce que moi
forcément il y en a toujours un petit
peu fort un mariage c'est normal mais
voilà on va être là pour les accompagner
et les aider au maximum et surtout ce
soit la décoration le traiteur la salle
de réception un photographe
on s'occupe de tout
voilà un an et demi qu'elle ont ouvert
leurs agences anaïs et florence située à
trappes
les deux organisatrices s'adapte à votre
demande selon la thématique est le lieu
[Musique]
le budget moyen d'un mariage avec 100
invités est d'environ 15000 euros
les wedding planner ont de nombreux
partenariats avec des salles de
réception encore des photographes en
faisant appel à elle vous fait environ
15% d'économies sur votre budget on est
là aussi justement pour négocier les
prix avec les prestataires ce que les
particuliers ne mousse pas ou ne demande
pas forcément donc nous avec avec nos
partenariats du coup on peut justement
essayer de de répondre à leurs critères
en rentrant dans leur budget et c'est ce
qui est assez compliqué de faire quand
on n'a pas de wazemmes canard anaïs et
florence prépare déjà des mariages pour
la saison 2010 8 pour bien organiser
l'événement il faut s'y prendre au moins
un an à l'as vence on referme cette page
sur le mariage on prend la direction de
versailles pour découvrir un coiffeur
pas comme les autres samuel cohen ne
travaille qu'avec des produits végétaux
depuis 20 ans un coiffeur écolo à
versailles un reportage de mélanie poker
là je vais rajouter un reflet il est
lui-même allergique aux produits
habituellement utilisés en 1997 samuel
cohen se lance dans la coloration 100%
végétale comme autrefois
je vous souhaite ma grand-mère faisait
elle même ses couleurs sa mère venue
toujours tout bébé j'aimerais travailler
ma grand mère sur ses couleurs de talent
et sa mère venue je suis il il faut il
ya possibilité avant autrefois avant
qu'enfin du chimique en faisait du
végétal en faut se préparer donc les
couleurs de nous-mêmes soi même les
coiffeurs
enfin il faisait ça donc je me suis mis
à faire chaque couleur est le fruit
d'une recherche minutieuse au bout de 20
ans samuel cohen peut proposer 29
couleurs à base de plantes de végétaux
et d'argile quand il ya la pose du
produit il n'y a pas cette sensation
qu'on a de brûlures de sensation de
voler au niveau du cuir chevelu
quand on rentre au niveau de l'odorat il
n'y a pas d'agressivité au niveau de
l'odeur tout et on sent que c'est
vraiment des produits qui se moque c'est
qu'ils sont pas notés aussi et ensuite
au niveau du jeu il est beaucoup plus
doux beaucoup plus doux et beaucoup
moins sec l'établissement versailles et
est labellisé développement durable des
institutions de la coiffure comme trois
autres salons dans le département
et c'est une première dans les yvelines
un escape game une sorte de plus de
grandeur nature vient d'ouvrir au
village des loisirs à maurepas ce jeu
d'évasion tout droit venues d'europe de
l'est propose de résoudre en 60 minutes
des énigmes en groupe on écoute la
responsable du centre
au micro de nicolas bay les gens sont
excités dans la salle ils sont partout
ça peut aller jusqu'à 6 et donc après
soit ils se dispersent mais travail en
équipe et c'est vrai que c'est assez
marrant de les voir ça à sa crise et dès
qu'ils trouvent un indice c'est waou
enfin je veux dire vrai c'est assez
assez sympa c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le
journal merci de nous avoir suivis et
surtout bonne soirée
[Musique]